whilst we started looking back again at
the idea of probability right which we
haven't looked at for a while but we
start off nice and gently with some
stage by probability you just chances
events and so on okay
in the last code is Thursday Friday we
did sort of have a look at this we sort
of went to one side and thought because
we come back to probability we thought
about arranging objects right um
arrangement is what I call this that's
what comes overview of arrangements you
saw the results they're not what you can
sort of read through okay I get it but
I'm some of the results this is really
about intuitively understanding what's
going on so I wanted to talk through
some of them anyway because in my
experience like literally when I went
through in year 12 and learnt this yeah
you can manipulate your formulas and
really have no concept of why they are
what they are so we're going to do that
this morning of therefore important
results which I've never even counted or
written which I hope to like either
establish for you or not just establish
but help you feel that are not just they
are right but they feel what this is
what this supposed to be okay so
therefore results and we'll come back to
probability when we think about are in a
given arrangement right what's the
probability that'll be this or that okay
so every agents what we're looking at
now I asked you to get one of every
color if you did it you should have I
think encounter ten your ten different
colors there so the first important
result is how many ways are there to
arrange or I should by the way I should
give the proper word for this is permute
right so arranged in order and that's
why we call these permutations but don't
close this bracket how many ways are
there to permeate these ten objects
okay now I'm gonna write that as my own
as my heading right how many ways to
arrange
and objects okay so I want you as much
as possible to put your hands on these
blocks and actually feel what's going on
that's it like I mean I could
demonstrate this all for you the demo
and all for you but in sexual half of
him you can execute him yourself
so underneath here what you need to draw
for you and this is a this is a massive
tool that like I mean remember I said to
you what's challenging that probability
and cozy clubs is there's no like set of
steps okay this is the closest to a set
of steps you're going to do right so how
many ways are there to arrange and
objects we can't physically look around
and objects because you don't know what
they are so let's go with Tim right so
if what I did was imagine a set of
places in which to arrange my objects
right so draw yourself or the line and
put in ten spots there we go okay so
here my 10 spots then you've got your 10
objects to choose from okay now when you
look at them you say alright well how
many can I fit into the how many ways
can I do the first one who you think
well I've got 10 to choose from so you
take one you say ok well they go I've
chosen one I've chosen one I had 10
options right so there are 10 options
for that first spot but having placed
the first one that red one over there in
the same way when we had a look at
probability trees and it's like okay if
I'm choosing things and as you progress
through you're like oh I don't know the
same number of choices anymore
so do the fractions that probability
that each my branches they change money
so in the same way here's our second
event in our multistage event for 10
stage event and for this guy because I
haven't replaced there's a different
number of options and you can see there
are 9 left over okay so then I say all
right I'm gonna pick one here we go
so after you've got nine and that you
can follow the pattern down down to one
okay now important I'll call you mine
back to probability we
you have a multi-stage event you've got
these numbers here and there are two
ways to combine them you either multiply
or you add which one is it and more
importantly why so someone tell me which
one it is how do I combine this I should
multiply why why do you multiply that
how can you convince me that I should be
multiplied end up adding a so you've
explained to me why this is 9 and then
this is a and then this is 7 but you
you've not convinced me why I should
just add these and get 55 ways each the
song someone ever done starts because
like you you're right idea is running
but it's not distinguishing between x
and okay so I'm suggesting I'm
suggesting that actually it is in a
specific order so these are permutations
and order matters you might have found
this in the textbook on wine selections
right
okay that's true so this is an
arrangement question not a problem the
only question but I still haven't got an
answer because in probability sometimes
I add sometimes I add I'm like all this
this video isn't it sir
why am i not multiple German aha
here we go alright good now I wonder if
I wonder if this calls you back to when
we were doing don't be enough to read it
when we're doing this right under what
what circumstances do we add and under
what circumstances do we multiply right
well we multiply of all branches right
like this one and then this one right we
multiply whatever number is here and
here to find out what happens
churches are different when you have x
and y right it's like look I'm rolling
two dice so I need a number on both of
them okay
whereas when do we add yeah with this
separate events like going down here you
know you can't have X Y and X Z so being
that you can have this or that you add
them right now here it's like one look I
want this everybody I want all of these
I need all ten together I want I want
colors on all of them right so that is
why we multiply and that's why this is
10 factorial okay so this is the
familiar is all not 10 plus 9 prepare
etc so in answer to the original
question like we use this as our model
10 objects if I had n objects instead of
two objects then the answer would be